oh my god seriously holy Shh I know this
is Italy but please oh my god hey guys
welcome back to potato mode the show
where we take the best looking games out
there and turn him into mush
my name is Joey I'm joined by jean-luc
psyche hello and we would like to thank
you for coming back to us after our a
couple week-long break thanks to e3 and
a bunch of other things that kept us
busy but we have returned with hitman
2016 yeah one of my favorite games you
were fighting for this for a game of the
year I remember
yackin 2016 is my top my number one game
of the year and I was trying to get it
into the top ten sadly I was shot down
enough supporters well I I am one of
them right now but that only is because
we would like to defy hit man's graphic
so if you want to jump in right now yeah
alright so we're in Paris we have to
infiltrate this gallery Fashion Show
type thing there's so many things you
can do this one there's a chandelier
there you can drop on people that camera
guy we messed up you can like take his
disguise and you can put explosives in
the camera yeah there's there's a lot
alright so that's our first deed we want
to kill here this is great because you
could also dress yourself up as one of
the fashion show people and then walk
the catwalk oh that's gonna be good we
are definitely gonna get that yeah we
got to do that there so this is where
they're all like getting ready yeah and
this is the guy Helmut Kruger
coincidentally looking a lot like agent
47 yeah people even comment on that
they're like wow you look just like
Helmut Kruger man that's crazy
I like how you just keep tossing bald
guys in the room oh let's get his face
makeup on okay I think that'll be the
perfect time to maybe switch over now
that we kind of know so what everything
looks like make us look beautiful wow
that is a hell of a makeup artist he's
not even doing anything he looks like a
Michael Myers mask wait a second all you
did was put a bag over my head now he's
just plastering it down onto his face
well thank you I will just not my own
this guy might be out of a job
by the end of the night Wow oh good this
is supposed to be a fashion show I love
you severe lack of fashion here great
for anything remotely resembling good
looks all right well let's walk this
catwalk all right whoa wait a minute
hold on before we do that what are these
priceless antiques man oh yeah just
thinking about the detail that you
mentioned earlier it's all gone it's all
going mmm check it it's so pale oh my
God look at this everyone's cameras is
like completely illuminated Oh like a
lot of people are really bald all of a
sudden your helmet Krueger you are
you're the one like pushing for this
this bald
Oh shopping yeah this is like you are as
a trendsetter here like once I know the
helmet Krueger's coming in they just
shave their head again something about
that specific thing I think it might be
like I candelabra where yeah it's just
not there agent 47 the trendsetter
creep I love it all right uh we can go
kill this woman he's also on his phone
has agent 47 ever used a cell phone
because I don't think that's know it's
the whole holds it back to this crowd
yeah
Wow there is just a lack of also these
are blue what I don't think they were
because they were supposed to be
illuminate or something like the lights
were coming out of the trees but now
there's just no trees or they're also
look at that water we were talking about
like the background looks so good - it's
just blobs yeah this is like crazy
like private auction thing you can
participate in as well oh is that what
they're bidding for god I would not pay
money for that what is that one like
it's see-through it's like a gelatin a
jello mold we got a potatoes potatoes
would be would be perfect I think and
then a pink slurry the thing they used
to make chicken nuggets yes delicious
that's what the people eat in this world
in the world of hit man this phase never
fails to amuse me so bad I feel like all
the games we could have picked I feel
like he has the one face of a
protagonist that is not going to be that
much affected by the potato code all
right
poisoned and then we can go ahead and
let me dump her out the window we could
that probably would cause an alarm so
we're gonna stupider in here done excuse
me not going as I planned
do you know who I am hello trap mmm
sorry guys this is a really weird
species given are we doing it we're
doing it anyway it's pandemonium now now
we just need to get out of here
everyone's kind of milling about like is
it good to go back this is not a fire
drill guys this is a chandelier dropping
guilt it killed several people tens of
thousands of pounds of glass and metal
do we make it out scot-free just leaving
and now we make a smooth escape mission
accomplished alright I say we do one
more wouldn't you want you wanna do one
more thing let's do the the second level
we all need to finish it but I say we
explore just a little bit because I know
that that level is a lot brighter it is
if you look a little interesting yeah oh
wow
man that looks a little bit worse that I
remember also um agent 47 has a wicked
sunburn he's he's protecting his head
but you have to realize that no skin
cancer and all that so make sure you
protect your arms the actual textures
are supposed to be like I'll count the
way it's cracked and and and like aged
you know look to the walls yeah it looks
like they didn't finish painting it gave
up halfway Peter was just really lazy
turn swing back up to the mountains well
here those blocks up there oh my god I
have no idea I want to say their houses
but anything goes on potato Mon honestly
just naturally forming perfect
rectangles I kind of want to do the the
where you pretend to be your lover the
lover one yeah that one's pretty good
dingdong who is it
oh it's just a hit man oh my god
seriously holy Shh
I was nice sorry sir I had the wrong
this is not the right oh no sorry I know
this is Italy but please oh my god
yeah you're right I clearly no no sir
Sir sir Sir adding insult to injury okay
all right so we're in here even though
we could have totally just walked in
like normal but you know figure why not
everyone has like reversed sunburns
whereas you just burn on your arms and
legs everyone gets their faces looks
like he's made out of like clay come on
man do something they'll just stand
around the Sun go somewhere where there
aren't people give him a little chef's
surprise mm-hmm delicious oh my god that
guy is really red I'm worried about them
do those sunglasses are not helping you
man so cool it's so hot here hey dude I
know you're throwing up but I'm gonna
choke you out which would probably
actually be very bad and kill you okay
so I'm gonna take his phone I'm just
gonna snap his neck which by the way
there was no animation to that we're
gonna just drag him into here at the
buff wait hello there I want us to meet
your room
I should say no but you won't
oh he's smooth how does she one think
that same based on the voice and T when
she sees something like wait a minute
you're not I mean in all fairness since
we did potato fire they all kind of look
the same anyway so that's probably why
she's just whatever we just gotta wait
in this room oh there's a romantic no we
all know from the last level that bald
is in I turned the sound on I got the
fire going you need the plague ducktor
outfit I didn't poison the champagne is
as good of a mood as I can get until we
have time to go get the bullet doctor we
don't I don't know if he does it with
that with that uh increase our chances
of wooing her like hello baby
I thought we'd do some role-playing it's
really bright no blinding oh there she
is shoot no quickly get in the mood
Cheers
[Music]
congratulations and that's how we do it
[Music]
killed my spaghetti alright guys I think
that about does it for this episode
potato mode once again if you have a
game that you'd like to see potato fide
and turned into stuff like this turned
into cans of spaghetti basically make
sure leave in comments tweet at us just
get your suggestions out there we have a
lot of games that we want to get around
to so make sure you're heard until then
we'd like to thank you we'll see you
next Friday bye have fun down there then
go around okay yeah you can do this oh
yeah let's see if this really is a
crowbar that is definitely a crowbar
Scott oh okay so now you're here you're
okay
yes that's okay but slow that